عندما داهمت قوات مشات البحريه الامريكيه
احدى مناطق باكستان العام الماضي كانت
النتيجه اكثر من مجرد قتل اسامه بن لادن
فقد اختبا زعيم تنظيم القاعده السابق ومعه
الالاف من الوثائق والتسجيلات الصوتيه
واشرطه الفيديو المحفوظه على اجهزه
الكمبيوتر والاقراص الصلبه واكثر من 100
جهاز اخر المحلل الامني لدى سي ان ان بيتر
برجن قام شخصيا بفحص بعض البنود اثناء
بحوثه لكتابه
الاخير يظهر على بن لادن القلق من الغارات
الجويه وينصح احد ابنائه بالخروج من
المناطق القبليه الباكستانيه وبسبب قله
الاموال كان يتحدث مع زملائه عن عمليات
الاختطاف التي كانت تلجا اليها القاعده
كوسيله لجمع الاموال وفي حين ان بعض
الوثائق التي ضبطت في مايو ايار الماضي
ستبقى سريه لاسباب امنيه فقد تم نشر 17
وثيقه اخرى عبر الانترنت الخميس الماضي
بواسطه مركز مكافحه الارهاب في كليه ويست
بوينت العسكريه وفيها يتضح اتباع ابن لادن
لمنهج معينه كانت تقف وراء تكتيكاته
الارهابيه بالاضافه للكشف عن بعض
اهداف كان يطلب تنفيذ هجمات على الولايات
المتحده والرئيس اوباما والجنرال ديفيد
بترايوس وقال انه لا يهتم بمحاوله قتل
نائب الرئيس جوزيف بايدون مره اخرى ووزير
الدفاع روبرت جيتس والامير مايك مولين
ودعى الى ضروره التركيز على هذين
الرجلين المعلومات المستقاه من كنوز بن
لادن الشخصيه ممكن ان تساعد الحكومه
الامريكيه للاستعداد بشكل افضل داخل
وخارجها واستباق التهديدات الموجهه
للولايات
المتحده